We mustache you a question — do you think
we live in a society that can handle
another secret Justice League 'stache?
Well, hold on to your razors, because footage
from the set of Zack Snyder's Justice League
reshoots just leaked — and it shows that Jared
Leto's character once sported a very stylish strip
of facial hair over his upper lip. Can
we get #releasethejokerstache trending?
For the longest time, when it came to the Justice
League movie, all anyone could talk about was
mustaches. That's because Henry Cavill was
contractually prohibited from shaving his Mission:
Impossible mustache when he did reshoots
for the 2017 theatrical version of the film,
and the VFX artists had to digitally remove
it in post-production. The effect was jarring,
and was yet one more reason so many fans wanted
Zack Snyder's original cut of the movie released.
But as it turns out, you can't keep
a good 'stache down — now you can
add yet another digital shave to
your list. Here's what happened.
"This is unbelievable."
Insiders tell us that Leto was thrilled about
Snyder's invitation to revisit the Joker role.
Before now, he'd only been able to play the Joker
in 2016's Suicide Squad, but Snyder wanted to
bring him back for the his new four hour vision
of Justice League. To prepare for the reshoots,
the infamously committed method actor decided to
dive deep into the history of the Joker on film,
blending bits and pieces from all of the actors
who came before him in his own performance.
He discovered that the very first actor
to play the part of the Joker — Cesar
Romero in the 1966 Batman television
series — refused to shave his mustache,
so the showrunners just covered it up with
white paint. Leto decided that the only way
to honor him was to grow a mustache of his
own...but with a signature Jared Leto twist.
In a leaked excerpt from a soon-to-be-published
interview with Follicle Monthly, Leto said:
"I needed to feel the spirit of Cesar within
me. So I found out where he used to live in LA,
and I used my Joker skills to break in. I stole
all the mustache wax and beard oil I could find,
rubbing as much as I could into my own
mustache and drinking whatever was left.
I now have the Romero essence."
"I love this guy! He's so intense!"
According to our source, when Leto showed
up on set, he'd already been in-character
as the Joker for over a month, having applied his
character's makeup weeks ago and grown his dark,
bushy mustache over it, which he'd also dyed
green. As he got ready to shoot his scenes,
Leto explained the mustache's backstory.
Apparently, after Darkseid's forces took
over the earth, the Joker's twisted mind
snapped even further. As the mustache grew,
the Joker began believing it was
his own sick, psycho sidekick,
which he named Harry — full name Harry Quinn.
He refused to shave Harry, believing his prickly
partner in crime was all that stood in the way of
the Earth being turned into the next Apokalips.
Snyder, knowing better than to ask Leto
to break character, and having limited
time to shoot the new scene, just got the
cameras rolling. Our sources on the set
reportedly heard Snyder defending the actor's
decision to worried producers, saying, quote,
"I know it'll cost us another $30 million, but
you gotta admit — it's a pretty good joke."
That said, Harry wasn't the only thing that
hit the cutting room floor. Apparently Leto
improvised several lines that directly referenced
his mustache — dialogue like, "Do you wanna know
how I got this mustache?"; and, "Did you ever
try to shave a mustache in the pale moonlight?",
and "Top this, Joaquin," and, finally,
"Wait'll they get a load...of this mustache."
Another source inside DC Comics' offices revealed
that Leto had actually sent the publisher
hundreds of letters demanding that the Joker be
drawn with a mustache for the next ten years.
As of the making of this video, DC
still has yet to comment on our question
about whether or not they might
want to add a little beard, too.
Most interestingly, our source said that
since footage of the mustache-cut leaked,
Leto has been cast in the upcoming direct-to-Quibi
spin-off, Mission: Impossible: Kitchen Nightmares.
What do you think of this startling revelation?
Are you Team Stachey, or Team
Shavey? Do you know what day it is?
"What a joke!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Snyder Cut are coming soon!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one!